tu as lu aujourd'hui c'est le nouveau
master class et dans ce nouveau master
class je vous parle de mnémotechnique
avec la mnémotechnique vous allez
améliorer votre capacité à retenir des
choses à retenir plein d'informations
qui n'ont pas forcément de sens comme
des listes de choses par exemple ça ça
n'a pas de sens des exemples valent
mieux que de longs discours donc je vous
donne quelques exemples et le premier
c'est moi vous avez forcément déjà tous
entendu parler de cette expression mais
où est donc ornicar et j'en ai bouffé
quand j'étais petit c'était pas facile
vous savez mais où est donc ornicar ça
permet de retenir les conjonctions de
coordination ça fonctionne parce qu'il
ya une petite musique derrière existe
d'autres procédés pour faire ça comme
par exemple les phrases avec un secret
caché à l'intérieur monsieur vous tirez
mal je suis un novice pitoyable avec la
première lettre de chacun des mots vous
allez retenir lors de des planètes dans
le système solaire donc monsieur vous
tirez mal ça donne le m pour mercure
vous s'est levé pour venus tirer c'est
le thé porte rmc le m 2 mars je suis un
novice pitoyable jupiter suis saturn un
uranus novice neptune et le p de pluton
parce qu'à l'époque vous croyez que
pluton faisait partie du système solaire
et puis bon oeil et colloques et des
discussions bref pluton fuite
exit là c'est une phrase complète
évidemment mais ça aurait pu être aussi
un seul mot composer avec toutes les
lettres qui nous intéressent comme dans
le code mnémo technique de vie du genre
début genre connaissait pas bibione
bijour c'est l'ordre des couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel levé pour violer le hideux
indigo le b de bleu et de vert wii u
vert on sait simplement que quand on
écrit bible genre en fait le but ça peut
avoir la forme un petit peu d'un v et ça
permettait d'avoir une voyelle
évidemment genre vous avez compris
c'était jaune orange et rouge donc avec
un seul mot on retient encore une fois
une liste d'informations en plus dans un
ordre précis qui nous intéresse dans les
procédés mnémotechnique intéressant il
ya aussi le fait de cacher en fait des
nombres à l'intérieur des mots à
l'intérieur de votre process comme dans
le légendaire poème que j'aime à faire
apprendre un nombre utile aux sages ceux
qui se cachent à l'intérieur de ce poème
c'est tout simplement pillé les
décimales de pi le nombre de lettres de
chaque mot correspond à une décimale de
pi d'un bon ordre évidemment que j'aime
à faire apprendre si on compte le nombre
de lettres de chaque mot ça fait 3,1
cadre 1
5 9 9 pour apprendre après deux puisque
c'est un vous pouvez regarder d'ailleurs
sur internet si vous voulez apprendre le
poème en entier et connaître encore plus
de décimales il ya une suite à ça
évidemment il mordait l'archimède
artistes ingénieurs qui de ton jugement
peut briser la valeur les procédés
mnémotechnique peuvent aussi servir dans
le quotidien pour des détails pour la
vie de tous les jours bientôt on sera au
mois d'avril au mois d'avril on change
d'heure et alors est ce qu'on avance
d'une heure où est-ce qu'on recule d'une
heure au mois d'avril avril ça commence
par avait comme avance l'autre
changement d'heure il a en octobre et
octobre ça finit par eux comme recul est
donc en avril on avance et en octobre on
recule
ouais ouais j'ai l'impression de faire
du port dans le même état d'esprit il ya
évidemment les stalagmites qui monte
parce qu'un m et les stalactites qui
tombe avec le thé à l'époque du
changement d franc à l'euro si j'avais
un moyen mnémotechnique comme pour celui
de pie ou si j'ai oublié de le dire là
il ya quelques secondes c'était la
phrase chacun sera enfin convertir notre
monnaie le nombre de lettres de chaque
mot correspondait au taux de conversion
de l'euro au départ changement de
monnaie donc 6,55957 je vous ai donné
tous ces exemples là pour vous montrer
que ça s'applique est un petit peu tout
a réellement plein de techniques
différentes plein de deux processus en
fait de méthodes pour créer de la
mnémotechnique et trouver de la logique
dans ce que vous avez à prendre surtout
quand c'est une accumulation de choses
qui n'ont pas trop de sens comme tous
les noms des rois troncy vous devez
apprendre tous les noms des rois de
france il vaut mieux se crée une phrase
ou un jeu ou un mot un peu comme pévu
genre là mnémotechnique en fait c'est un
moyen qui va permettre de faciliter la
récupération des informations qui sont
dans votre cerveau c'est-à-dire que vous
savez des choses
vous les avez appris c'est quelque chose
que vous avez vraiment imprégnés et
votre moyen mnémotechnique c'est un
petit peu votre rail votre guide pour ça
ou alors ça peut faciliter aussi un
petit peu comme un aide mémoire des
informations un peu binaire ou ternaire
vous savez comme la pour octobre et
avril est ce qu ont reculé ce qu'ont
avancé meilleurs procédés mnémotechnique
que vous pouvez utiliser c'est ce que
vous inventez pour vous avec votre
logique à vous et vos méthodes à vous je
vous incite à le faire c'est l'objet de
ce master class aujourd'hui vous allez
augmenter au moins par deux la manière
dont vous allez trier les choses dans
votre cerveau la manière dont vous allez
créer vos dossiers dans votre disque dur
mental
alors vous allez commencer à organiser
vraiment votre mémoire et à devenir
hyper efficace là dedans et c'est ce que
je souhaite évidemment
servez que vous pouvez aussi sous titrée
cette vidéo si vous avez quelques
minutes ou plutôt quelques heures c'est
toujours un peu long à faire j'ai ouvert
les sous types des vidéos vous pouvez
sous-titré celle ci très utile aussi
corriger les fautes d'orthographe qui se
cachent dans les sous titres
collaboratif qui ont été faits par
d'autres abonnés ou peut-être même par
vous-même merci à tous d'avoir fait ça
vous vous passez du temps dessus c'est
un truc vraiment ça me touche ça me fait
plaisir que vous fassiez ça voilà là
c'est moi qui vous met un pouce en l'air
mais peut-être que vous êtes en train de
faire pareil pour cette vidéo je serais
ravi qu à la fin de cette vidéo vous
abonner à la chaîne g1 petits moyens de
les mots techniques pour pas que vous
oubliez qui est ici tout de suite comme
ça vous n'oublierez va le faire ça
permet de faire connaître encore plus la
chaîne a encore plus de personnes
passaient un excellent week-end et
rendez vous demain à 11 heures pour le
prochain mandat le blog ciao